hi my name is Manny Rheingold and I will
be your host for this issue of Google
developers live and today we're focusing
on DIY dork and DIY org is a site and a
community where kids can learn new
skills and share what they've learned
and each member gets a portfolio where
they can show off all the skills that
they've learned everything from like
beekeeping and dancing to astronomy and
filmmaking and rapid prototyping and
today I am joined by four different di
wires from around the world all tuning
in through Google hangout and they've
all earned programming related badges so
we want to learn more about how they
learn to program and how people like you
guys can help so first I want to turn it
over to Diana from DIY to tell us a
little bit more about DIY yeah so DIY as
you said is an online community for kids
can learn different skills and what's
really awesome about it is that we see
this sort of community sort of
dynamically growing by themselves kids
are basically teaching themselves these
skills and collaborating with other
members and their variety communities in
ways of through creating their own
websites or starting DIY newspapers and
collaborating with one another to
complete projects and earn skills that
they've never sometimes never even heard
of before cool and so let's turn it over
to the DIY errs themselves I'd love for
you guys to each introduce yourself oh
I'll start then uh hi my name's Zach I'm
a DIY er both like on the site and I
also work for DIY so I think that's
that's cool so I'm sixteen
my favorite programming skill I mean
I've done the log I'm just kind of
testing I'm when working but definitely
like the front-end developer and
back-end developer those like kind of my
favorites of mine unlike programmer ones
you know for I know that Todd for one is
one that's really fun to do great silly
hi I'm Zoe I'm eight years old and my
favorite DIY scale that's not related to
programming is meme hacker name hacker
do you know what kind of programming do
you know I program mostly in Python
cool awesome
HTML oh man front-end and back-end cool
hail I will you introduce yourself hello
uh my name is uh you like to joke and
I'm on di one stuff and I really like
the the open-source er junior high
school because I really like the whole
like community aspect of coding and
stuff like that and open like DIY is an
open source community has helped me as
well as like other open suits so open
source is very good like learning
research for me and how it helped me
learn a lot of stuff but really and then
my my other skill that I like that's not
craft coding is the or phonologists kill
I really I really like that skills um
it's about birds and stuff and her like
birds and bird watching nature and stuff
so yeah nice and last but not least
Ginny will you introduce yourself hi I'm
Ginny I'm 11 years old and I've earned
new I think that's about it but my
favorite skill that isn't programming is
animator whoa cool aw that's awesome you
guys have done so many things I love it
um so just to learn a little bit more
about DIY and why you guys love it so
much Eli will you share us with us your
favorite thing about DIY oh yeah my
favorite thing about DIY is that it's as
I said before that's like an open
community that like you could learn so
many things from other people like like
you could you could teach other people
things like oh let there's no like like
it's all it's like a
it's like a learning experience as well
as a fun one it's like like a lot of
times like like experiences can be
educational and fun like but like one is
higher than the other but I like how DIY
is exactly like 50% it's really nice how
you learn a lot and you also have like
tons of fun at the same time it's very
it's very I like it a lot so that's my
favorite thing but education and the
fund balance yeah it seems super
collaborative too like I noticed you can
comment on projects and fork projects
yeah it's really like there's lots of
like you don't just post something and
then it's just there like people like
you could come and fork it which means
they like people if they have the same
ideas you they can like they could share
with you can they can show their idea
like as well as yours and then there's
like favoriting and then there's like
you can get featured as well which is
like you're featured on the homepage and
so like it's really like communities
like it's like a community it's a very
nice community yeah cool and and since
we want to learn more about how you guys
start to learn programming
jinnie tell us more so you've earned the
new badge so why did you start why did
you decide to earn that skill well three
days after Christmas I dropped all my
Christmas presents and went and followed
this link from the newb skill which was
to mi t--'s programming website scratch
oh the cool kids it really got me
started and then I got into Khan Academy
after that and from there I learn
JavaScript and I'm getting a little bit
into uhm HTML really interested in that
this is all since Christmas
yes whoa that's Christmas okay who's
that that was that's a muddy crazy speed
that's awesome
so you've been coding for like a year
now yes really cool and then in so Zoey
you're eight and I've heard that you've
known
that you have wanted to be a programmer
since you were five so I'd love to learn
more about like what inspired you to
want to become a programmer and what do
you want to do with these skills when
you grow up
well my parents introduced me to Khan
Academy and my favorite part of that was
the coding so then she me to another
website for coding and then I started
learning Python from a book whoa cool
what have you what have you have you
made anything with with Python or any of
the yeah code that you've learned not it
much yet though okay we got an early
start feel good about your your future
as a programmer got a lot of years ahead
of you um and and Zak so you're you're
here and you're actually you've you've
actually grown up to be a programmer as
a teenager so I want to hear more about
that like what's it like to actually be
a programmer for DIY and you're still in
high school right yeah in high school I
mean it's good yeah I like I've always
been kind of a fan of like teenagers
getting out and doing more than you know
the average part-time job which I guess
is what has led me like to DIY and so I
started about a year and a half ago I
guess and it's like I mean when I
started I definitely was not that good I
mean you know thought I was okay yeah it
was it's and it's just been like a
really great ride I mean like well the
people I work with are great they're you
know great mentoring and just overall
good people and I've learned so much and
I've done some like I've got to speak
and I've got to do so many things
because of programming which it's that's
I think it's bad to get school yeah I'm
excited to see your project later on
cool and so um when you're just starting
so I want to learn more about how you
guys actually learned how to program so
Jenni will you will you start to tell us
about how you learned you that you
mentioned scratch and khanacademy
earlier
well I just went in to scratch followed
some of their tutorials I see I was
figuring a lot of things out on my own
um my first project was just this
picture of a ninja and if you press
different buttons on the keyboard then
he would change poses nice fighting
ninja from there I progressed so much in
the first couple weeks and I just took
off and I was making a lot of things
from generators to platformers cool and
he like will you share with us more
about how you started to learn how to
program oh when I was like younger when
I was like eight I started like I got
into I I read a lot and I really want to
start like a website cuz about book
reviews is sort of like a like a dream
or whatever and then like I saw I was I
researched a little bit I figured out
that I could actually do this somehow
and I used on a couple of like small
soft words when you use HTML mostly and
I sort of like started creating my
website like at first it started with
just like a blank background and then
like a couple bodies of text but then
eventually and then learned more and
more through the internet like I like my
website progressed and of course it's
not published or anything cuz I just
just serve like a like a it's like a
page thing it wasn't like on the
Internet
but it was a like that's how I got into
coding was by I go on and have this
website and I researched I just found
out that no it's actually possible cool
and then how have you progressed
three-year learning through DIY oh well
with DIY like as I said before like I
just knew like like it just in just HTML
like just the basics but then I went on
DIY like the skills like a back and down
in front of Dave introduced me to all
other types of code and how those codes
work like Raptor how it's like back in
dev and stuff
and in CSC put CSS and that really helps
with like spicing up my book my HTML and
stuff like there's not like I learned I
learned different codes that could help
me out through my website making and
like other stuff cool yeah cool
and since so most of our listeners are
grownups and so I want them to walk away
knowing how they can go help kids like
you the tap program so Zoey have there
been any adults that have helped you
along the way and anything that made it
super helpful or not helpful for you to
learn how to program yes my dad has
helped me with Python and you know
taught me how to like make it so you can
like it asks you a question you can type
an answer you know give you or so cool
yeah it's so magical when it actually
responds is there anything that your dad
has done too that's made it easier to
learn how to code well he gave me the
book about Python super helpful which
what book is that it's Python for kids
oh cool
sounds like an appropriate book for you
cool awesome
um I would love to actually see a demo
so Zach will you share the coolest thing
that you've created with code yeah
totally so let me just pull it up so
this was kind of start off as a joke
project it's called dos script so if you
ever seen the Doge meme on internet
which you know quickly becoming very
overused but still funny I kind of
started this as a joke basically I was
like what if there is a programming
language that was based on the Doge meme
and would compile to JavaScript like how
all of this you know CoffeeScript in
typescript and so I kind of did it one
night as a joke and then this is what
happened a lot of people started
contributing
and I posted it while someone else had
posted it on Hacker News and it just
kind of blew up so a lot of people found
it and it became this was like so many
people were really into it and it's just
cool I it's like it's on github so like
open-source MIT license and people like
they've contributed so many things pull
requests and I mean there's 15
contributors for what's a completely a
joke language
but it's it's it's a good joke language
but at the same time it's you could
actually program things and people have
which is really funny to see the beauty
of the internet love it and the wowzer
it's great cool well this has been super
fun for me um before we sign off are
there any like last advice anyone wants
to share to the Google developers out
there that are tuning in I would say
when you're trying to get kids and
teenagers interested don't like over
force it on them like so many people try
to like really force ants like if a kid
or teenager doesn't like it they don't
like it and move on to something else
they're passionate about it that's
that's like kind of biggest if I think
if it means that's for anything but
really for programming it's definitely
true yeah love that and go like help
kids learn what they're passionate about
thank you guys this has been super fun
and Google developers out there I hope
you've been inspired by these young kids
who already know how to code and you're
excited about going out and helping more
kids in your community learn how to code
there were some great resources that
they mentioned and also remember to
check out DIY org